[Musique]
Véronique que l'on retrouve Michel David
et Christian Dufour bonsoir
encore un chapitre sur le salaire des
élus monsieur le groupe qui a défendu sa
hausse Véronique vous étiez à cette
mêlée de presse vous allez entendre on a
collé deux extraits dans le deuxième
extrait c'est le nouvel argument parce
que Michel avait de vous dire pourquoi
les députés allaient les mieux payés non
non il dit attention il faut comparer
les députés du Québec avec les députés
d'Ottawa national
d'attirer
les meilleurs d'attirer des gens
compétents et puis je reviens mon
exemple de jeunes Pâques ou mère de
famille je vois pas pourquoi
secteur privé secteur public payerait
mieux que la politique faut valoriser le
rôle des députés puis parfois il faut
apporter des du rattrapage si vous
comparez kotawa parce que oublions pas
que le Québec une nation qu'on a à gérer
des pouvoirs
identitaires que d'autres provinces ont
pas à gérer donc
on va rester en bas des salaires à
Ottawa
je monte les chiffres puis je vous
laisse parler donc parce que au Québec
ça va devenir
131.000 donc la province où on paie le
plus les députés mais comparé à la
Chambre des communes en effet c'est en
deçà alors chef David ça répond à votre
question
non surtout pas l'argument de Monsieur
de monsieur Legault écoutez je comprends
qu'elle Ottawa fait plus d'argent puis
qu'on est une nation là mais quand le
Québec sont indépendant on fera un autre
comité et puis on montera les salaires
mais regardez les responsabilités
monsieur LEGO à beau dire que nous on
s'occupe d'identité puis qu'on fait
passer en Ontario mais on s'occupe pas
d'ingérence chinoise là ici puis on sait
que pas de cheminer AXA pour on s'occupe
pas de la guerre en Ukraine là c'est
monsieur Legault compa vraiment des
pommes et des oranges alors j'achète pas
du tout sur son argumentation et mais ce
qui me frappe c'est un peu l'entêtement
monsieur Legault c'est-à-dire que c'est
le premier gouvernement ça fait
peut-être un demi siècle la constitue
scanne là-dessus qui va passer outre la
règle non écrite qui voulait que ce soit
une année et monsieur Legault
comment dire une mauvaise foi je pense
quand il nous dit bah oui mais c'est un
comité indépendant qui le recommandé
puis on prend ses recommandations
tripartite sauf que le comité en
question avait un mandat tellement
étroit qui pouvait pas examiner
l'ensemble la rémunération par exemple
les allocations et le fond de retraite
c'est ça qui change toute la donne un
fond de retraite tellement généreux que
qui est pas qu'il y a pas d'équivalent
ailleurs alors
de façon générale j'achète pas je monte
une autre salade de Monsieur Lego et je
vous montre une autre donnée un sondage
commandé par Québec solidaire faut quand
même le dire ou la question elle vous
d'accord d'augmenter de 30% le salaire
des députés 74 en désaccord 20% en
accord j'ai même été surpris que ce soit
juste 74% qu'on demande si le 30% frappe
beaucoup
Véronique c'est ce qui a donné un autre
tour à neige aujourd'hui entre autres
oui parce que Québec Solidaire a
commandé ce sondage là comme on vient de
le dire mais en même temps il se
contredisent aujourd'hui c'est une
mauvaise journée pour Québec soldat
davantage que pour François Legault vous
allez me dire qu'à la fin de la session
les gens ce qu'ils vont retenir c'est
que François Legault et son gouvernement
sont ceux qui auront fait passer cette
augmentation de salaire là c'est vrai
puis qu'avec solidaire a toujours été
compte c'est vrai que c'est ça que les
gens vont retenir par contre une journée
fait pas nécessairement la semaine mais
aujourd'hui on était une mauvaise parce
que il se contredit Québec solidaire
veut faire de l'obstruction en ce moment
parce que c'est le seul levier qu'ils
ont étant donné que le gouvernement est
imposant majoritaire c'est le seul
levier pour montrer leur contestation de
déposer plein d'amendements puis essayer
que ça dure le plus longtemps possible
pendant ce temps-là ça fait mal paraître
le gouvernement mais un des amendements
c'était de proposer d'augmenter le
salaire à 110000 puis peut-être à 120
000 mais en même temps ça avait l'air
d'être sorti d'un chapeau parce qu'il
pour justifier d'où provenaient ce
chiffre là exactement puis là ce qu'ils
disent ben écoutez nous ce qu'on essaie
de faire c'est à moindre rire la hausse
au lieu que ce soit 30 000 ce serait
peut-être 20 000 ou peut-être 10000 mais
en même temps ils ont l'air de manquer
cohérence là
vous avez suivi ça aujourd'hui c'est
Québec sur le DAB je vais vous faire
écouter plus tard mais qui dit bon ben
propose un comité pour ralentir le
comité bon mais 20 000 ce serait correct
là c'est là où on comprend plus beaucoup
là c'est une grosse erreur tout d'abord
fait ça parce que leur position au
départ était très très forteustensile
pour une Mustang fait penser un peu au
capitaine Haddock dans Tintin le fait
tournesol celui quand tu es le sparadrol
il y a le plaster le Suédois le PC de
s'en débarrasser puis splaster revient
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps c'est un dossier je pense qu'il va
qui va vraiment le hanter parce que
franchement j'ai écouté notre premier
ministre pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'affections je dis souvent mais c'est
la mode franchement comme argumentaire
puis de toute façon moi je persiste ces
signes un pour déterminer le salaire de
députés faut les payer assez faut pas
les pieds trop il y a pas de comparaison
à faire avec les autres professions
parce que c'est une profession qui est
unique puis comme Michel le dit l'erreur
fondamentale c'est qu'on a pas de compte
de l'ensemble du dossier comme la
jugement quand il répète et je vous
relance là tu quand il répète monsieur
Legault oui mais attention il y avait un
député du Parti québécois il y avait un
député du Parti une député du Parti
libéral il y avait il y avait déjà
représentés c'est n'importe quoi je
trouve Patrice son argumentaire est
tellement faible c'est un peu gêné pour
lui et puis à ce que dit Véronique aussi
je trouve que c'est n'importe quoi
parce que c'est un argument d'abord il y
a pas répondu que quand on lui a dit oui
mais ils vont être ils vont ils sont la
comparaison avec l'Ontario ils vont ils
vont être plus payés que l'Ontario il y
a pas répondu hier soir il vient tout le
temps avec l'idée que c'est des gens qui
travaillent fort puis qui ont le droit
d'avoir de l'argent puis il faut attirer
des des gens des autres secteurs qu'on
soit compétitif moi je trouve que ça
tient vraiment pas la route mais en même
temps moi parce que Québec solidaire moi
quelque part je trouvais que c'était un
bon leur dossier peut aussi sont en
train de le gâcher en étant pas capable
de se tenir debout puis de dire on tient
notre fil mais franchement pour Monsieur
le gosse ces gens-là on va écouter
quelque chose sur François Legault au
fil de mes discussion avec les
différents députés là à 90 députés dans
un caucus là mon maudit que le plus dur
à convaincre ça avait été François
Legault parce qu'il était pleinement
conscient de l'image que ça allait
projeter puis de la critique que ça a
attiré puis du fait que ça allait
omnubilé tout le reste puis prendre
toute la place à la fin de la session
mais quand tu as 90 députés puis que
majoritairement ils veulent avoir
l'augmentation mais j'ai comme
l'impression qu'il fait pour ces députés
là
mais ce qui aurait pas été possible de
faire correctement les choses d'accord
je ben
je peux continuer à revenir mais à ça
puis Michel je vous entends de là-dessus
parce que je vous me dit oui mais le
mandat du comité était restreint
c'est-à-dire le comité devait se pencher
sur le salaire
mais il n'avait pas à regarder
totalement les fonds de pension etc mais
c'est quand même un comité avec un
piquet une libéral puis un cake qui ont
un ex qui ont décidé ça là il y avait
quand même les bras attachés ce
comité-là ça aurait eu du sens une
augmentation de cet ordre là si par
ailleurs on avait ajusté le régime de
retraite qui qui est scandaleux bien
honnêtement ok on écoute Gabriel à dos
Dubois qui lui a essayé de se
dépatouiller Véronique nous disait t'es
eux ils proposaient 20 000 au lieu au
lieu de zéro enfin au lieu de 30 000 on
écoute
je constate que ces amendements longs
ont généré des questionnements sur la
position de Québec solidaire on réécrira
pas le passé ce qui est important pour
moi aujourd'hui c'est dire clairement la
position de Québec solidaire depuis 10
ans n'a jamais changé on est contre
toute augmentation qui serait
voté par les députés eux-mêmes je
constate que ça génère de la confusion
et des questions on l'avait pas vu venir
bon pas une bonne journée aujourd'hui
comme j'ai dit Véronique
qui avait fait sa force et qui avait
jamais vacillé il y avait jamais changé
de position je début jusqu'à la fin
quelles que soient les critiques qu'il y
avait tenues sont beaux puis il a gagné
je trouve que avec solidaire quelque
part il y avait un dossier très gagnant
mais là je vois qu'ils ont perdu mais
ils ont gâché quelque chose parce que on
a l'impression que c'est plus de la
démagogie mais de la stratégie politique
qui ne conviction profonde motion du NPD
aujourd'hui à la Chambre des communes je
vous fais entendre un échange à la
Chambre des communes motion qui est déjà
une qui demande le retrait de
monsieur John Stone pour la suite des
choses on écoute
va-t-il
arrêter de son ami de
la
fin déclencher une enquête publique
est-ce que le premier ministre va avoir
la dignité et le sens de l'état de le
créer et de faire une commission
d'enquête indépendante et publique
est-ce que le premier ministre va enfin
prendre au sérieux ces allégations et
déclencher une enquête publique nous
allons continuer de prendre cet enjeu
aux sérieux nous allons continuer de
laisser les faits et l'intelligence
recueilli par nos agences guidés nos
réflexions et nos actions là-dessus
alors Christian je commence avec vous
tour de table monsieur Trudeau
manifestement ne va pas renvoyer
monsieur Johnston qui va continuer lui à
des audiences publiques qu'il veut
diriger etc il veut posséder il veut pas
perdre la face même si il se retrouve un
peu seul contre tous mais la position
qui me semble quand même un peu spéciale
c'est celle de Jack médecine d'une
parce que des facto on est confronté un
gouvernement de coalition et puis le
moment c'est que ça brille pas parce
qu'on courage bon parce que là ils vont
avec les autres parties d'opposition il
suit le vin en fait mais là il envoie le
message à l'effet qui mettra pas la
survie du gouvernement en jeu donc si le
gouvernement maintient que vous ne
semblez le passé moi je suis pas sûr à
100%
en fait tient son bout je trouve que
déjà victime va avoir l'air très très
fou quelque part ça fait un peu
opportuniste moi je trouve pas que ça
brille par par son courage pas parce que
je vais avoir des élections mais pour
qu'un autre système se tient le moment
donné il y a des dossiers fondamentaux
puis si jackmotting tu trouves que c'est
une
erreur fondamentale peut-être qu'il
pourrait laisser un petit doute sur son
attitude au final alors qu'il y a versé
à l'avance que de toute façon le
gouvernement risquerait si tenté il
croit vraiment que Johnson doit quitter
le crois-tu profondément et comme vous
dites vous avez utilisé le mot vent tout
à l'heure à Michel quand pensez-vous bah
je pense que Monsieur Trudeau a pas le
choix que que de refuser parce que s'il
dit bon c'est vrai monsieur Johnson n'a
pas la crédibilité pour mener les
audiences publiques ça veut dire qu'il y
avait pas la crédibilité pour mener son
premier examen non plus et à partir de
ce moment-là tout le rapport sur lequel
monsieur Trudeau s'appuie pour dire
qu'il y aura pas d'enquête publique
serait serait dévalorisé alors il y a
pas le choix que tenir son bout
maintenant dans le cadre monsieur signe
monsieur signe veut pas d'élection il y
a certains que si se laisse embarquer
jusqu'à en faire une affaire de motion
de confiance
le tout tout sa stratégie tout s'écroule
tous ces creux exactement et et c'est
vrai je suis convaincu
réel volonté de forcer monsieur Trudeau
à prendre des initiatives comme
l'assurance dentaire etc qui est tout à
fait sincère mais il se trouve
effectivement avoir l'air un peu
hypocrite dans cette histoire là
Véronique un mot
c'est une motion qui n'est pas
contraignante mais c'est embarrassant
puis fait François Philippe champagne le
dit aujourd'hui la chambre elle est
souveraine elle peut faire ce qu'elle
veut mais nous en bout de ligne en
gouverne alors c'est eux qui décident
finalement d'un autre côté je me dis
monsieur Johnston va probablement
lui-même finir par se poser la question
concernant sa légitimité parce que là le
débat est en train de faire diversion
est-ce que sa présence à ce que lui-même
est en train de culter tout le reste je
suppose que lui-même doit être en train
quand même de faire cette réflexion-là
bande parce que Monsieur Johnson semble
quand même assez près de Monsieur
Trudeau le salut supposer des intentions
malveillantes que ils comprennent que ça
arrangerait bien du monde si de lui-même
il laissait la place en tout cas il a
écrit exactement le contraire en fin de
semaine dans les journaux et en français
et en anglais en disant
je vais rester oui Michel ouais je sais
pas si ça arrangerait monsieur Trudeau
parce qu'il y a eu déjà eu de la
difficulté à trouver quelqu'un pour
faire le premier rapport alors il y a
peut-être pas le goût dans la chambre de
quelqu'un de la nouvelle de l'Australie
quelque part contre d'aller chercher
quelqu'un qui est vraiment en dehors en
fait de l'aquarium canadien pour toi
quelqu'un qui est beaucoup de
crédibilité on disait pour parle
pourquoi pas aller chercher en fait un
haut fonctionnaire australien il y a des
gens qui ont imagination
rapport du commissaire des langues
officielles c'est un peu le jour de la
marmotte ça revient on écoute Raymond
Théberge comme ça aux langues qui
parlent d'Air Canada et Ginette petit
patelin ensuite
les Canadiens les Canadiens ont très
bien assimilé le concept des langues
officielles comme étant une valeur
fondamentale canadienne les manquements
qu'on constate cette année depuis
toujours c'est tout simplement ça
démontre que nous institutions n'ont pas
encore
assimilés dans au sein de leurs
organisations l'importance des langues
officielles et que on doit résoudre des
problèmes systémiques le fait de ne pas
respecter les droits linguistique d'une
communauté
ça démonte sans possiblement un manque
de respect
le Commissaire aux langues officielle la
seule chose qui avait le droit de faire
ce qu'on veut c'est de enquêter et puis
de faire des recommandations maintenant
avec le projet loi C13 l'adoption puis
la sanction royale de ces 13 quand même
le commissaire pour imposer des
sanctions administratives pécuniaires
pour chaque infraction qui est apportée
compte
donc comment ça va vous elle dit le
nouveau commissaire avec ma nouvelle loi
aura des dents celui-ci n'a pas dedans
oui mais d'abord ce que Monsieur théver
dit que la population a accepté que les
deux langues officielles c'est une
valeur canadienne pas certain que c'est
si répandu ça comme comme valeur au
Canada anglais
d'autre part les dents j'ai hâte de voir
il y a par exemple prenons Air Canada il
y a 276 plaintes c'est probablement la
pointe de l'iceberg c'est pas tout le
monde qui porte plainte même si c'est
irrité du service écoutez monsieur
Théberge il est prévu qu'il peut donner
des amendes jusqu'à 25000 dollars par co
évidemment si les 200 KK ont chacun une
amende de 25000 dollars puis ça fait 50
millions là j'imagine que Air Canada va
réagir mais c'est pas ça qui va faire
moi j'ai hâte de voir combien de
d'amende au niveau du distribuées une
deux et si c'est ça là c'est pas
dysplasif du tout pour Air Canada
Christian Air Canada c'est vraiment une
des entreprises fédéral dans le dossier
du des services en français et le plus
critiquable parce que beaucoup aussi de
contact avec les citoyens puis à la
ferme à quelle Rousseau qui a quand même
attiré l'attention sur cette institution
fédérale donc la question qu'on doit se
poser là comme Michel je pense tous
est-ce que les nouvelles mesures les
chiatives Ottawa vont changer quelque
chose c'est bien beau de flamanter puis
dire on veut être respecté on commence à
être à devenir très très bon les
francophones là-dessus au Canada et moi
ce que j'espère c'est que non seulement
il y a des sanctions mais que des
sanctions financières extrêmement élevé
parce que moi je suis convaincu que ça
va être la seule façon que Air Canada
réagisse parce que même beau les belles
paroles hypocrite sur rupaulus moi je
suis capable des entendre si la nouvelle
législation doit être appliquée puis il
faut qu'elle soit appliquée qui paye
cher c'est comme ça qu'ils vont
comprendre dans la langue qu'il
comprenne monétaire ce Véronique Klein
oui puis monsieur Thérèse je disais
aussi qu'il veut publiciser les amandes
donc peut-être que ça ça aura un effet
encore plus dissuasif puis du côté de
qué aujourd'hui on grimpait pas dans les
rideaux parce que on me disait oui mais
en plus Air Canada s'est inscrit à l'eau
qLF pour être accompagné dans un plan de
francisation donc ils ont une volonté
quand même le faire donc on va peut-être
voir une différence mais la question
c'est est-ce que c'est une réelle
volonté aussi c'est une opération de
relation publique parce que les autres
entreprises à Chartres fédéral ont fini
par s'inscrire
c'est le lieu de se poser cette question
là aussi je voulais vous parler mais ce
sera pour la prochaine fois de Daniel
Smith de ce que ça va changer on a parlé
hier dans les rapports fédéraux fédéral
provincial on va en reparler une autre
fois je vous dis merci bonsoir à la
prochaine au revoir